Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Metrolinks and Crosslinks are reminding everyone to be careful, as Eglinton Crosstown LRT train testing is in progress. Please be alert, as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks, and only make left turns where it's safe to do so.
感谢您收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需收听每周的额外剧集、享受无广告体验、抢先观看系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。Metrolinks 和 Crosslinks 提醒大家注意安全，因为 Eglinton Crosstown 轻轨列车正在进行测试。请保持警惕，因为列车随时可能在轨道上通过。请务必遵守所有交通信号。在轨道沿线请小心谨慎，仅在安全的情况下进行左转。
Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. There was one Pope, or to be more accurate, a Popess, who is not included in the list of the bishops of Rome. This is because she was a woman. She disguised herself as a man and became, by virtue of her character and talents, first a secretary in the papal court, and then a cardinal, and finally pope. One day, while climbing onto her horse, she went into labour and gave birth to a child. Immediately, in accordance with the dictates of Roman justices, she was bound by her feet to a horse's tail and dragged for half a league while the people stoned her. When she died, she was buried at the spot where she had breathed her last, and an inscription was written there, Petre, parta patrum, papice prodoto partum, which is to say, Peter, father of fathers, make known the childbearing of the Popes.
请保持警惕，提高意识，注意安全。曾经有一位教皇，或者更准确地说，是一位女教皇，她没有被列入罗马主教的名单中。这是因为她是一位女性。她女扮男装，凭借自己的品格和才华，先是成为了教皇廷的秘书，然后是红衣主教，最后成为了教皇。有一天，当她骑上马时，她开始分娩并生下了一个孩子。根据罗马司法的规定，她立即被双脚绑在马尾上，被拖行了半里格，同时人们向她投掷石块。她死后，被埋葬在她咽下最后一口气的地方，并在那里刻下了一段铭文：“Petre, parta patrum, papice prodoto partum”，意思是：“彼得，众父之父，揭示教皇的生育。”
So that was Jean de Mailly, who was a Dominican chronicler writing the early 13th century. And that, Tom, is a remarkable moment in the history of the Catholic Church, isn't it? It is, isn't it? A female pope, a popess, who gives birth while getting onto the horse and is then stoned to death by her own adherents. So first of all, did this happen? And secondly, what is going on? What is going on? I'm not aware of any female popes. Right. So this is the very first mention of a female pope. Jean de Mey gives a very precise date, which is 1099. So maybe 120, 130 years before he's writing. The pope in this passage is not named, but it is written up a lot over the decades and centuries that follow.
那是让·德·梅伊（Jean de Mailly），一位生活在13世纪初的多米尼加编年史家。汤姆，这是天主教会历史上一个非凡的时刻，不是吗？确实如此，不是吗？一位女教皇，在骑马时分娩，然后被她自己的追随者用石头砸死。那么首先，这件事真的发生过吗？其次，这到底是怎么回事？到底发生了什么？我不知道有任何女教皇。没错。这是关于女教皇的第一次提及。让·德·梅伊给出了一个非常精确的日期，即1099年。所以这可能发生在他写作前120或130年。这段文字中没有提到教皇的名字，但在随后的几十年和几个世纪里，这个故事被多次记载。
And the pope is generally known as Joan. So Pope Joan. And the story attains probably its canonical form in the mid-13th century with a chronicler and bishop, again, a Dominican like Jean de Mailly called Martin of Poland. And he writes a chronicle of all the popes and all the emperors. And he's actually the first person to have the brilliant idea of kind of setting popes and emperors in separate columns so that you can kind of cross-reference them. And the story he tells is in its outline, he sets it Martin of Poland. And so this is the one that goes into the mainstream of tradition. That in the early ninth century, so well before 1099, there is an English woman who
这位教皇通常被称为琼（Joan），即琼教皇（Pope Joan）。这个故事在13世纪中期达到了其经典形式，由另一位多米尼加编年史家兼主教，即波兰的马丁（Martin of Poland）所记录。他撰写了一部关于所有教皇和皇帝的编年史。他实际上是第一个想到将教皇和皇帝分列在不同栏目中，以便进行交叉参考的绝妙主意的人。他讲述的故事大纲由波兰的马丁设定。因此，这就是进入主流传统的故事版本。在9世纪初，也就是远在1099年之前，有一位英国女性……
was born in Mainz, so presumably of English parents. In Germany. In Germany. She disguises herself as a man because she has a lover who goes off to become a clerk. And this is a very kind of exclusively masculine environment for him to go in. And so the only way that Joan can follow her lover is to disguise herself as a man and go off and become a clerk, a student, a scholar as well. And she turns out to be absolutely brilliant. She has a brilliant, brilliant scholarly brain. And she studies first in Athens, we're told, and then she goes to Rome. And in Rome, she attracts the attention of the papal court. And so she is brought into the papal court. She ends up a
出生在美因茨，所以大概是英国父母所生。在德国。在德国。她女扮男装，因为她有一个去当职员的情人。对他来说，这是一个非常排外的男性环境。所以琼跟随情人的唯一方法就是女扮男装，去当一名职员、学生，同时也是一名学者。结果她表现得非常出色。她拥有极其聪慧的学术头脑。据我们所知，她先是在雅典学习，然后去了罗马。在罗马，她引起了教皇廷的注意。于是她被带进了教皇廷。她最终成为了一名……
cardinal, as Jean de Mey said, and then she gets elected Pope. Crikey, that's a twist. And she takes the name of John. This pontificate, according to Martin de Poden, lasts for two years. Not only has she disguised herself as a man, but she is continuing to have sex. So very unpapal behaviour all round. Well, it depends on the Pope, I suppose, doesn't it? I mean, definitely becoming pregnant is unusual for an heir of St. Peter. And as in the account that you read out, she gives birth in public and Martin of Poland specifies that it takes place
红衣主教，正如让·德·梅伊所说，然后她被选为教皇。天哪，这真是个反转。她取名为约翰。根据波兰的马丁的说法，这个教皇任期持续了两年。她不仅女扮男装，而且还在继续进行性行为。所以这在各方面都是非常不符合教皇身份的行为。嗯，这取决于教皇是谁，我想，不是吗？我的意思是，怀孕对于圣彼得的继承人来说确实是不寻常的。正如你读到的那段记载，她在公共场合分娩，波兰的马丁明确指出，这发生在……
during a public procession from St. Peter's in the Vatican to the Lateran Palace, which is the palace that was given to the papacy by Constantine. So it's in the heart of ancient Rome. And Martin specifies that this passageway is a narrow street that was once known as the Sacred Way, and it runs between the Colosseum and San Clemente, the great church where to this day, you can go deep down into the depths and ultimately reach all the way down to the Roman street level. And Martin says that ever since this shocking episode, the popes have made a point of avoiding the street, although this street is the most direct route from the Vatican to the Lateran. Right. And just to put this into some context for our audience, Tom, the extraordinary thing about all this, in case you know nothing of Christianity and Catholicism,
在从梵蒂冈的圣彼得大教堂到拉特兰宫的公共游行期间，拉特兰宫是君士坦丁大帝赠予教皇的宫殿。所以它位于古罗马的中心。马丁指出，这条通道是一条狭窄的街道，曾经被称为“圣道”（Sacred Way），它位于斗兽场和圣克莱门特大教堂之间，在那座伟大的教堂里，直到今天，你仍然可以深入地下，最终到达罗马的街道水平。马丁说，自从这起令人震惊的事件发生以来，教皇们一直刻意避开这条街道，尽管这条街是从梵蒂冈到拉特兰最直接的路线。没错。汤姆，为了给我们的听众提供一些背景，关于这一切最非凡的事情是，如果你对基督教和天主教一无所知的话……
is that women aren't even allowed to be priests, let alone to be popes. So a woman pope challenges the very basis, one of the foundations of Catholic Christianity. And so it would seem. And this is why the penalty as described by Jeanne de Mey is so terrible that she's dragged on a horse and stoned. But Martin of Poland, fans of Pope Joan will be relieved to hear, gives a slightly more upbeat resolution to the story, which is that John isn't killed, but deposed. And he does many years penance. And the child that she has given birth to is a boy, and he becomes the bishop of Ostia, which is the port of Rome, so at the mouth of the Tiber. And in due course, when she dies,
那就是女性甚至不允许成为神父，更不用说成为教皇了。所以一位女教皇挑战了天主教基督教的根基，即其基础之一。看起来确实如此。这就是为什么让·德·梅伊所描述的惩罚如此可怕，她被马拖行并被乱石砸死。但波兰的马丁，琼教皇的粉丝们会感到欣慰的是，他给出了一个稍微乐观一点的结局，即约翰并没有被杀，而是被废黜了。她进行了多年的忏悔。她生下的孩子是个男孩，他成为了奥斯蒂亚（Ostia）的主教，也就是罗马的港口，位于台伯河口。后来，当她去世时……
he buries his mother with all honor in the cathedral of Ostia. So it's an odd story. It is. And you might think that it's just a kind of mad folk tale. I mean, where's it come from? Except that for two to three centuries, pretty much up to the 16th century, it's believed to be true. So the chronicle list that Martin of Poland has written is accepted by the church as definitive. Pope Joan appears in this list. So it's basically got the imprimatur of the Roman church. And all kinds of substantiating evidence seems to have emerged. So there is the fact that the popes don't take this road.
他以所有的荣誉将他的母亲安葬在奥斯蒂亚大教堂。所以这是一个奇怪的故事。确实。你可能会认为这只是一种疯狂的民间传说。我的意思是，它是从哪里来的？除了在两到三个世纪里，几乎直到16世纪，人们都相信它是真的。所以波兰的马丁所写的编年史列表被教会接受为权威。琼教皇出现在这个名单中。所以它基本上得到了罗马教会的认可。而且各种各样的佐证似乎也出现了。比如教皇不走这条路的事实。
There is the fact that certainly by the 15th century, if you're a visitor to Rome, you can go to the spot where she is meant to have been stoned or had the baby and see this inscription that you read out, Petrae pata patrum papice prodita partum. Come on, Tom, you can do it. Which is supposedly said by the devil. Yeah. And also you can see a statue of Pope Joan marking the spot where she died. Now, that statue presumably is some ancient Roman statue of a woman that they found and put up.
事实上，至少到15世纪，如果你是罗马的游客，你可以去她被认为被乱石砸死或生孩子的地方，看到你读到的那段铭文：“Petrae pata patrum papice prodita partum”。来吧，汤姆，你可以读出来的。这据说是魔鬼说的。是的。而且你还可以看到一座纪念她去世地点的琼教皇雕像。现在，那座雕像大概是他们发现并竖立起来的一座古罗马女性雕像。
Right. But it is believed genuinely to mark the spot where she is killed. Yeah. And in the great cathedral of Siena that we talked about in the episode about Catherine of Siena, they were planning a massive extension of it in the Black Death. It gets stopped by the eruption of the plague. But they sculpt a whole series of images of the various popes, and Pope Joan appears in this list. And she's labelled John VIII, a woman from England. So hold on, Tom. For about 250 years, maybe even 300 years, people lived and died believing that there had been Pope Joan. Yeah. John VIII, a female pope. Yeah.
没错。但人们确实相信它标志着她被杀的地方。是的。在我们在关于锡耶纳的凯瑟琳（Catherine of Siena）那一集中谈到的宏伟的锡耶纳大教堂里，他们在黑死病期间计划对其进行大规模扩建。但由于瘟疫的爆发，工程被迫停止。但他们雕刻了一系列历任教皇的图像，琼教皇也出现在这个名单中。她被标记为“约翰八世，来自英国的女性”。等等，汤姆。大约250年，甚至可能是300年，人们生活并死去，相信曾经有过琼教皇。是的。约翰八世，一位女教皇。是的。
Crikey. But more than that, Dominic, that the church is giving its imprimatur to it. I mean, that's what's really, really odd. And then, of course, what happens in the 16th century is that you have the Reformation. And this is exactly the kind of story that Protestant propagandists love. Of course. And so they start making all kinds of mischief with it. And the Roman church becomes ever more kind of embarrassed by the story.
天哪。但不仅如此，多米尼克，教会还给予了它认可。我的意思是，这才是真正非常奇怪的地方。然后，当然，16世纪发生了宗教改革。这正是新教宣传者喜欢的那种故事。当然。所以他们开始利用它制造各种麻烦。而罗马教会对这个故事变得越来越尴尬。
And then by 1601, Clement VIII definitively declares the legend to be untrue. And so it is then kind of parked. Will you say the legend? That presupposes that it is a legend rather than an embarrassing story that they want to suppress. Correct. Right. So the obvious question is, where does this story come from? I mean, what are the origins of it? And as you say, one obvious solution would be that it is true, that Pope John really did exist. It has to be said that there are scholars today who do make the case for it, but they're very, very much in a minority.
到了1601年，克莱门特八世最终宣布这个传说是不真实的。于是它就被搁置了。你说“传说”？那预设了它是一个传说，而不是他们想要压制的尴尬故事。没错。所以显而易见的问题是，这个故事是从哪里来的？我的意思是，它的起源是什么？正如你所说，一个明显的解决方案是它是真的，即约翰教皇确实存在过。必须说，今天确实有一些学者提出了这种观点，但他们是非常非常少数的。
Pretty much since the 17th century, everyone, say Protestants as well as Catholics, have tended to assume that it's a legend. In fact, it is a Protestant from France, a guy called David Blondel, who publishes a dissertation in 1647 in which Edward Gibbon, writing the following century, says that Blondel annihilated Pope Joan. He goes through all the sources for it. He sifts it and evaluates it. I mean, this is very much what Protestant scholars are doing in the 17th century. They're going over all these kind of ancient stories that are told about the church and kind of demonstrating that they are fantastical. So the details that Blondel is marshalling to demonstrate that Pope Joan can't possibly be a true story.
几乎从17世纪开始，每个人，无论是新教徒还是天主教徒，都倾向于认为这是一个传说。事实上，是一位来自法国的新教徒，一个叫大卫·布隆德尔（David Blondel）的人，在1647年发表了一篇论文，爱德华·吉本（Edward Gibbon）在下一个世纪写作时说，布隆德尔“消灭”了琼教皇。他查阅了所有相关的资料。他对其进行了筛选和评估。我的意思是，这正是17世纪新教学者们所做的事情。他们审视所有关于教会的古老故事，并证明它们是虚构的。所以布隆德尔用来证明琼教皇不可能是真实故事的细节……
I mean, the classic one, which I'm sure you will have picked up on, is that the account, the first mention of the female Pope takes place a long time after the events that they're describing. So even if it's in 1099, I mean, that's still over a century. And if it's in the ninth century, then that's 300 years and there is no mention of her whatsoever. But Tom, we've said so many times on this podcast, the sources for Alexander the Great or any of these things are written long after the event. Well, as I remember, you and I had a slight disagreement about the reliability of those sources. I think you'd now admit you were wrong, wouldn't you? Of course you would. No, I don't think I would. Because the thing is that it's
我的意思是，最经典的一个，我相信你已经注意到了，就是关于女教皇的第一次提及发生在他们所描述的事件发生很久之后。所以即使是在1099年，那也已经过了一个多世纪。如果是在9世纪，那就是300年了，而且根本没有关于她的任何提及。但是汤姆，我们在播客中说过很多次，关于亚历山大大帝或任何这些事情的资料都是在事件发生很久之后才写的。嗯，我记得你和我对这些资料的可靠性有过一点分歧。我想你现在会承认你错了，不是吗？当然你会的。不，我不认为我会。因为问题在于……
not as though we lack sources from the 11th century. 1099 is the year that Jerusalem gets captured by the first crusaders. A lot is going on. We have a lot of material. There is no mention of this whatsoever. And even the ninth century where the sources are definitely more sparse. So Martin of Poland places Joan very precisely between the pontificates of two popes. One is Leo III, who was by the standards of ninth century popes, very formidable and impressive. And another one, Benedict III, who's the guy who receives the young Alfred the Great, you remember, who goes on pilgrimage to Rome. Oh, yeah. And gives him his sword and gives him his consul's cloak and all that kind of thing.
并不是说我们缺乏11世纪的资料。1099年是第一次十字军东征占领耶路撒冷的那一年。发生了很多事情。我们有很多材料。根本没有提到这一点。即使是在资料肯定更稀缺的9世纪。所以波兰的马丁将琼非常精确地置于两位教皇的任期之间。一位是利奥三世，按照9世纪教皇的标准，他非常强大且令人印象深刻。另一位是本笃三世，他就是接待了年轻的阿尔弗雷德大帝（Alfred the Great）的那个人，你还记得吗，他去罗马朝圣。哦，是的。并给了他剑，给了他执政官的斗篷等等。
Yeah. A consul's regalia. Yeah. And there's no place for Joan. They succeed one another. So it seems improbable, to put it mildly. Now, Martin of Poland describes Pope Joan as having ruled as John VIII. So you may wonder, well, was there a John VIII? And there was, but he definitely wasn't a woman. And he didn't rule for two years. He ruled for 10 years. He was a very formidable figure. The Saracens were busy launching raids deep up towards Rome, sometimes sailing up the Tiber. He is busy combating that. He's a considerable diplomat. He's marshalling allies across Italy against the Saracen threat.
是的。执政官的徽章。是的。而且没有琼的位置。他们是继任的。所以这看起来不太可能，说得委婉一点。现在，波兰的马丁将琼教皇描述为以约翰八世的身份统治。所以你可能会想，那么，有没有约翰八世？确实有，但他绝对不是女性。而且他没有统治两年。他统治了10年。他是一个非常强大的人物。撒拉逊人忙于向罗马方向发动袭击，有时甚至沿着台伯河航行。他忙于对抗这些。他是一位相当出色的外交官。他正在意大利各地集结盟友以对抗撒拉逊人的威胁。
He doesn't die while giving birth. He is actually, in the best tradition of popes in the 9th century, poisoned and clubbed to death by his rivals in the church. But a question, Tom. You say he's definitely not a woman. I mean, how do you know? I think it would have been mentioned. He's not publicly a woman. He's certainly not publicly outed.
他并没有在分娩时死亡。他实际上，按照9世纪教皇的最佳传统，被他在教会中的竞争对手毒死并用棍棒打死。但有一个问题，汤姆。你说他绝对不是女性。我的意思是，你怎么知道？我想这会被提及的。他不是公开的女性。他当然没有公开出柜。
Right. Okay. Fine. He's busy negotiating with people and marshalling, you know, alliances and things. And I think people would probably have noticed if he wasn't. It would have been spotted is what you're saying. Yeah. I imagine there's a lot of academic theorists at work today who would have, you know, very
好吧。没关系。他忙于与人谈判并集结联盟等等。我想如果他不是，人们可能会注意到。你是说会被发现的。是的。我想今天有很多学术理论家在工作，他们会有……
complicated things to say about a story, Tom, but let's not get into that thicket. They do. Yeah. Obviously, I mean, it's of great interest to feminist and LGBT scholars, but I mean, I don't think they would say it was true. They would find it interesting as it is interesting because of what it says about the nature of gender and so on. But I don't think they are saying it's true. Basically, it's not true. I mean, it really isn't true. I think we can definitively say it's not true. It didn't happen.
关于一个故事，汤姆，有很多复杂的说法，但我们不要陷入那个泥潭。他们确实有。是的。显然，这对女性主义和LGBT学者来说非常感兴趣，但我的意思是，我不认为他们会说这是真的。他们会觉得它很有趣，因为它揭示了性别本质等等。但我不认为他们在说这是真的。基本上，这不是真的。我的意思是，它真的不是真的。我想我们可以明确地说它不是真的。它没有发生。
So the next item in your notes I read is distorted memory of the... This is not a misprint. No. The pornocracy. The pornocracy. The pornocracy. What is the pornocracy? So the pornocracy is a phrase that was used by later generations of historians of the church to describe the papacy in the ninth century. They call it the pornocracy.
所以你笔记中的下一项我读到的是“扭曲的记忆……”这不是笔误。不。色情统治（Pornocracy）。色情统治。什么是色情统治？所以色情统治是一个被后来的教会历史学家用来描述9世纪教皇制度的短语。他们称之为色情统治。
They do. And it reflects the fact that this is absolutely the low point for the moral standing of the Bishop of Rome. Because it's basically, it's not just that Rome is under attack from the Saracens. It's also that it is the plaything of very, very powerful rival dynasties in Rome, and particularly of women. And so the idea that the papacy is a plaything of powerful women. To clerics writing later, this is seen as- Pornographic. Porn is a prostitute. So this is prostituting the church, but also it's the implication that
他们确实这么称呼。这反映了一个事实，即这是罗马主教道德地位的绝对最低点。因为基本上，这不仅是罗马受到撒拉逊人的攻击。这也是因为它成为了罗马非常非常强大的敌对王朝，特别是女性的玩物。所以教皇制度是强大女性玩物的想法。对于后来写作的神职人员来说，这被视为——色情。Porn是妓女的意思。所以这不仅是在出卖教会，而且还暗示……
the women who are getting their hands on the papacy are themselves whores. Getting their hands on in every sense, Tom, presumably. Well, completely. So David Blondel in his, you know, the Protestant in 17th century France, he focused on one of these pornai, these prostitute, powerful women in Rome, as they were characterized, who was actually a remarkable woman called Marozia. And I mean, she wasn't just the most powerful woman in Rome during her lifetime. She was the most powerful figure in Rome. She was an absolute power broker. And so inevitably, she was viewed by outraged clerics in the most disobliging terms. So Leoprand of Cremona, who's a brilliant historian of this period, he goes to Constantinople and
那些掌握教皇权力的女性本身就是妓女。汤姆，大概在各个意义上都掌握在手中。嗯，完全是。所以大卫·布隆德尔，那个17世纪法国的新教徒，他关注了这些Pornai之一，这些在罗马被描述为妓女的强大女性，她实际上是一位了不起的女性，名叫马罗齐亚（Marozia）。我的意思是，她不仅是她一生中罗马最强大的女性。她是罗马最强大的人物。她是一个绝对的权力掮客。所以不可避免地，她被愤怒的神职人员以最不讨好的词汇来看待。所以克雷莫纳的利奥普兰德（Leoprand of Cremona），他是这一时期一位杰出的历史学家，他去了君士坦丁堡，并……
gives a sensational description of an audience with the emperor. And he's fabulously rude about everyone, but he's very, very rude about Marozia. He describes her as a shameless whore who ruled the Roman people as though she were a man. So you could see perhaps there's a kind of distorted echo there. But she goes one stage further and she arranges for her son, who is only 21 years old, to become Pope. He takes the name of John XI. And a further source of outrage for clerical chroniclers is that he himself is said to have been the son of a Pope, that Morozzi had had an affair with Sergius III. Textbook papal behavior, Tom. And so Edward Gibbon, the great author of The Decline of the Roman Empire, who loved all this stuff. Of course he did. I mean, there was nothing he enjoyed more than popes behaving badly. He says of the 9th century
对与皇帝的会见进行了耸人听闻的描述。他对每个人都非常粗鲁，但他对马罗齐亚非常非常粗鲁。他形容她是一个无耻的妓女，像男人一样统治着罗马人民。所以你可以看到也许那里有一种扭曲的回声。但她更进一步，安排她年仅21岁的儿子成为教皇。他取名为约翰十一世。对于教会编年史家来说，另一个愤怒的来源是，据说他本人就是一位教皇的儿子，马罗齐亚曾与塞尔吉乌斯三世（Sergius III）有过一段恋情。教科书式的教皇行为，汤姆。所以爱德华·吉本，那部《罗马帝国衰亡史》的伟大作者，他喜欢所有这些东西。他当然喜欢。我的意思是，没有什么比教皇行为不端更让他享受的了。他谈到9世纪时说……
that the bastard son, two grandsons, two great-grandsons, and one great-great-grandson of Morozia, a rare genealogy, was seated in the chair of St. Peter. Thomas Cromwell would have loved all this, Tom, wouldn't he? So it's an interesting theory. And actually, Blondel isn't the only guy who kind of proposes this as a possibility. So in the 16th century, there's an Italian historian of the papacy, a guy called Ornifrio Panvinio, who suggested that the story of Pope Joan derived from the guy who is possibly the worst, the most shocking, the most badly behaved Pope of all time, who ruled between 955 and 964, another John. So perhaps kind of echoes of Joan. And he was John the 12th. He becomes Pope when he's still a teenager. So kind of 17 or 18.
马罗齐亚的私生子、两个孙子、两个曾孙和一个玄孙，这是一种罕见的家谱，坐在了圣彼得的宝座上。托马斯·克伦威尔（Thomas Cromwell）会喜欢这一切的，汤姆，不是吗？所以这是一个有趣的理论。实际上，布隆德尔并不是唯一一个提出这种可能性的人。所以16世纪，有一位意大利教皇历史学家，一个叫奥诺弗里奥·潘维尼奥（Onofrio Panvinio）的人，他建议琼教皇的故事源于那个可能是有史以来最糟糕、最令人震惊、行为最恶劣的教皇，他在955年到964年间统治，另一个约翰。所以也许是琼的一种回声。他就是约翰十二世。他还是个少年时就成为了教皇。所以大概17或18岁。
He became Pope as a teenager. That's bonkers. That is bonkers. And Dominic, kind of doubling down on that, he ordains a boy who's 10 as a bishop. So if you're a young boy and you want to get on in the Catholic church, this is definitely the time to have been born. Start early. I think a lot of people would say 11 or 12 is too late to be a bishop. He variously blinds and castrates priests who offend him. He's reputed to have toasted the devil and he dies in the midst of sexual congress, Dominic.
他十几岁就成了教皇。这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。多米尼克，加倍强调这一点，他任命了一个10岁的男孩为神父。所以如果你是一个年轻男孩，你想在天主教会中出人头地，这绝对是出生的好时机。尽早开始。我想很多人会说11或12岁当神父太晚了。他随意弄瞎并阉割冒犯他的神父。他被认为曾向魔鬼敬酒，并且在性交中去世，多米尼克。
Of course he does. Either of an apoplexy or at the hands of his mistress's outraged husband. Right. Who's presumably not the person he's having Congress with, I would assume. No. And he has lots of these mistresses. So Leoprand says of him that he turned the latter into a brothel. And one of these mistresses was supposedly called Joan. So this is the theory. But again, the problem is that there is absolutely no trace of how these traditions would have evolved. There's no kind of hint of them. So again, I don't think that that is the explanation. And Dominic, it may not surprise you to learn that my explanation would be that it emerges out of perhaps the most significant revolutionary movement in European history, the great revolution that has been largely forgotten because it was so successful,
他当然会。要么是中风，要么是死于他情妇愤怒的丈夫之手。没错。我想那大概不是他正在与之进行性交的那个人。不。他有很多这样的情妇。所以利奥普兰德说他把拉特兰变成了妓院。而其中一个情妇据说是叫琼。所以这就是理论。但同样，问题在于完全没有这些传统是如何演变的痕迹。没有任何暗示。所以同样，我不认为那是解释。多米尼克，如果我告诉你我的解释是它可能源于欧洲历史上最重大的革命运动，那场因为太成功而被遗忘的伟大革命，你可能不会感到惊讶……
the Gregorian revolution, it's called, after Gregory VII, the great pope in the 11th century, who was the standard bearer for it. I don't want to imply, Tom, in what follows, any form of disapproval of this subject or weariness or anything like that. I want to convey to the audience great enthusiasm. Brilliant. Thank you. However, I will say, for the second time in about three weeks, you have smuggled in a discussion of theology and one of your pet subjects beneath an ostensibly Sandbrook-friendly, crowd-pleasing title. Is that fair to say? What the listeners don't know is that three minutes before we started
格列高利改革（Gregorian revolution），以11世纪伟大的教皇格列高利七世（Gregory VII）命名，他是这场改革的旗手。汤姆，我不想在接下来的内容中暗示对这个主题有任何形式的不赞同或厌倦。我想向听众传达极大的热情。太棒了。谢谢。然而，我要说的是，在大约三周内第二次，你把关于神学和你的一个宠儿主题的讨论，塞进了一个表面上看起来对桑德布鲁克（Sandbrook）友好、讨好大众的标题之下。这样说公平吗？听众不知道的是，在我们开始之前三分钟……
this program, I'd sent Dominic notes long ago and he confessed he hadn't read them. Yeah, last night. Last night. So that's your problem. I'm afraid that is entirely your problem. I was loving this. The pornocracy, whores, the blatter in a brothel, and then I turn the page, the Gregorian revolution. Oh no. Okay, Dominic, let's get back to 1099, which is the year that John de May gives as the date of Pope Joan. Does anything significant happen in this year? Well, yeah, we've mentioned the capture of Jerusalem by the first crusade, but there is also a key event, which is that Urban II, the Pope who had launched that crusade, dies and is succeeded by a guy who takes the name of Pascal II. And both these men are key players in the papal revolution.
这个节目，我很久以前就发给了多米尼克笔记，他承认他没读过。是的，昨晚。昨晚。所以那是你的问题。恐怕那完全是你的问题。我喜欢这个。色情统治、妓女、妓院里的拉特兰，然后我翻了一页，格列高利改革。哦，不。好吧，多米尼克，让我们回到1099年，这是让·德·梅伊给出的琼教皇的日期。这一年发生了什么重要的事情吗？嗯，是的，我们提到了第一次十字军东征占领耶路撒冷，但还有一个关键事件，那就是乌尔班二世（Urban II），那位发动十字军东征的教皇去世了，继任者是一个取名为帕斯卡二世（Pascal II）的人。这两个人都是教皇革命的关键人物。
And in essence, it's a hugely complicated subject. But essentially, the key motivation in the Gregorian revolution is this idea that the universal church has to be freed from the grubby clutches of earthly rulers, that there is a dimension of the cyclone, which is earthly, which is fallen. And then there is this dimension where religio joins the fallen earth to the radiant eternity of heaven. It's this that generates what will become the great divide between the secular and the religious, which becomes the defining feature of West European culture. To force through this sense that the church has to be freed from the hold of kings and emperors and so on. Reformers seize control of the Roman church and all these popes are kind of pushing
本质上，这是一个极其复杂的主题。但基本上，格列高利改革的关键动机是这个想法，即普世教会必须从世俗统治者的肮脏魔爪中解放出来，存在一个世俗的维度，它是堕落的。然后存在一个维度，宗教将堕落的地球与天堂辐射的永恒连接起来。正是这一点产生了后来世俗与宗教之间的大分裂，这成为了西欧文化的定义特征。为了强行推行这种教会必须从国王和皇帝的控制中解放出来的意识，改革者夺取了罗马教会的控制权，所有这些教皇都在某种程度上推动……
it forward. And whereas in the beginning of the 11th century, emperors are arriving in Italy and appointing popes, by the end of it, this is anathema to any pope. And instead, popes are being appointed by cardinals. So it's in the 11th century as part of this reform program that cardinals take on the role that they still have today, the College of Cardinals. These are the people who vote on the papacy. And these cardinals are drawn from across the whole of Christendom. And this is the key point. And I think that this is what provides the context for it. And the guy who argues this is a brilliant French historian, Alain Bourreau, whose book on Pope Joan is really wonderful.
它向前发展。而在11世纪初，皇帝们来到意大利并任命教皇，到了11世纪末，这对任何教皇来说都是诅咒。相反，教皇是由红衣主教任命的。所以正是在11世纪，作为这个改革计划的一部分，红衣主教承担了他们今天仍然拥有的角色，即红衣主教团。这些人是投票选举教皇的人。这些红衣主教来自整个基督教世界。这是关键点。我认为这正是提供了背景的地方。提出这一观点的人是一位杰出的法国历史学家阿兰·布罗（Alain Bourreau），他关于琼教皇的书真的很棒。
It's by miles the best book out there on the subject. And Bourreau points out that when Pascal II goes through the ritual of being a pope, before he's crowned in the Vatican, there is a similar kind of coronation in the Lateran palace. And for the first time, a pope is described as sitting in twin chairs in the Lateran. And these twin chairs are very, very distinctive because they still survive. There is one in the Vatican Museum. There's one in the Louvre.
它是目前关于这个主题最好的书，没有之一。布罗指出，当帕斯卡二世经历成为教皇的仪式时，在他在梵蒂冈加冕之前，拉特兰宫也有类似的加冕仪式。而且第一次，教皇被描述为坐在拉特兰宫的双人椅上。这些双人椅非常非常独特，因为它们至今仍然存在。梵蒂冈博物馆里有一把。卢浮宫里有一把。
And both of them have holes in the seat. So what are they? They're like toilet seats. Well, toilets or bidets or perhaps birthing chairs. But they are very, very beautiful. They are traditionally described as being made of porphyry. So very, very grand. And they retain a definite antique Roman aura. And these chairs, these thrones link the Lateran palace back to ancient Rome, back to the time of Constantine, but also even earlier than Constantine. Because I think that the key question is, why is Pascal sitting in two chairs? What's the significance of that?
它们两个的座位上都有洞。那么它们是什么？它们就像马桶座圈。嗯，马桶或坐浴盆，或者可能是分娩椅。但它们非常非常漂亮。它们传统上被描述为由斑岩制成。所以非常非常宏伟。它们保留了一种明确的古罗马光环。这些椅子，这些宝座将拉特兰宫与古罗马联系起来，回到了君士坦丁时代，甚至比君士坦丁更早。因为我认为关键问题是，为什么帕斯卡坐在两把椅子上？这有什么意义？
And in the ritual where he's being crowned, these chairs are described as curule chairs. And curule chairs are the chairs that the consul sat on. Okay. Yeah. So the consuls are the two leading magistrates in the Roman Republic, but they last right the way through under the emperors as well. These are the heads of the Roman state. And if the Pope is sitting on these two chairs to symbolize the fact that he is the heir of the consuls, then that is to cast the cardinals as the heirs of the Senate. Right. So they're deliberately taking up the
在加冕仪式中，这些椅子被描述为“库鲁尔椅”（curule chairs）。库鲁尔椅是执政官坐的椅子。好的。是的。所以执政官是罗马共和国的两位主要行政长官，但他们在皇帝统治下也一直存在。这些是罗马国家的首脑。如果教皇坐在这两把椅子上，象征着他是执政官的继承人，那么这就是将红衣主教塑造成元老院的继承人。没错。所以他们是在刻意继承……
classical legacy. That's an unusual thing, isn't it, for Christians to do? They are, because it's giving a dignity to the cardinals and to the papacy that precedes the emergence of the empire. So what the papacy is doing is saying that as the heir of the Roman consuls, his office is older than that of Augustus. And this is very popular. So you have all kinds of propagandists for the Gregorian reform. So one of them describes cardinals as the spiritual senators of the universal church. I think you can see very clearly that the use of these two chairs with the holes in them is a very specific response to a specific moment in papal history.
古典遗产。这对基督徒来说是一件不寻常的事情，不是吗？他们确实在这样做，因为这赋予了红衣主教和教皇制度一种先于帝国出现的尊严。所以教皇制度所做的是说，作为罗马执政官的继承人，他的职位比奥古斯都的还要古老。这非常受欢迎。所以你有各种各样的格列高利改革的宣传者。其中一人将红衣主教描述为普世教会的精神元老。我想你可以非常清楚地看到，使用这两把带洞的椅子是对教皇历史上特定时刻的非常具体的反应。
I like the detail about the chairs. I'm curious how you're going to link that to the legend of Pope Joan, because this would sound like a weird question, but where do the holes fit in to her story? Right. So I think the holes in 1099 are coincidental. What matters is the fact that these are very grand chairs. But what happens is that the specific context of 1099 comes to be forgotten. But as is the nature of rituals, popes, when they become pope, continue to sit in these two chairs. And so inevitably, 100 years on, people are wondering, well, what's going on?
我喜欢关于椅子的细节。我很好奇你将如何把这一点与琼教皇的传说联系起来，因为这听起来像是一个奇怪的问题，但这些洞在她的故事中起什么作用？没错。所以我认为1099年的洞是巧合。重要的是这些是非常宏伟的椅子。但发生的事情是，1099年的具体背景被遗忘了。但正如仪式的本质一样，教皇在成为教皇时，继续坐在这两把椅子上。所以不可避免地，100年后，人们想知道，嗯，发生了什么？
What's the thing about them? What are the holes for? Yeah. What are the holes for? And by 1290, so we've had 100 years of stories of Pope Joan by this point, you have a chronicler called Geoffrey de Coulon who writes about Pope Joan, deriving his account from Martin of Poland, but adding his own spin. And he says that because of the scandal of Pope Joan, and I quote, the Romans established the custom of verifying the sex of the elected Pope through an opening in the stone throne. Imagine being the person who had to do that, to lie underneath the chair and look up. has to kind of reach underneath and go up with his hands and then announce in Latin, habet duos testiculos et bene pendentes. And I guess that even if you don't know Latin,
关于它们的事情是什么？这些洞是干什么用的？是的。这些洞是干什么用的？到了1290年，所以此时我们已经有了100年的琼教皇故事，有一位编年史家叫杰弗里·德·库隆（Geoffrey de Coulon），他写了关于琼教皇的故事，他的叙述源于波兰的马丁，但加入了自己的一些内容。他说，由于琼教皇的丑闻，我引用：“罗马人确立了通过石制宝座上的开口来验证当选教皇性别的习俗。”想象一下成为那个必须做这件事的人，躺在椅子下面往上看。必须伸手进去，用手摸索，然后用拉丁语宣布：“habet duos testiculos et bene pendentes”。我想即使你不懂拉丁语……
you can work out what that means. He has a pair of bollocks and they are hanging down very nicely is basically what it says. Right. Nice. But obviously this rite never existed, but it serves to explain why they're sitting on these chairs and it can be related to the story of Pope Joan. And I think that that's a brilliant solution. I mean, a kind of wonderful explanation for it. The question then is, is it an adequate explanation for the story of Pope Joan? Yeah, because how does that explain the whole complicated story about being English, being born in mounts, coming to the throne, being stoned? I mean, I can see that people would say, well, they had the chairs with the host because once there was
你也能明白那是什么意思。基本上就是说：“他有一对睾丸，而且垂得很好。”没错。很好。但显然这个仪式从未存在过，但它有助于解释为什么他们坐在这些椅子上，并且可以与琼教皇的故事联系起来。我认为这是一个绝妙的解决方案。我的意思是，一种美妙的解释。那么问题是，这对于琼教皇的故事来说是一个充分的解释吗？是的，因为这怎么能解释关于她是英国人、出生在美因茨、登上宝座、被乱石砸死的所有复杂故事呢？我的意思是，我可以看到人们会说，嗯，他们有带洞的椅子，因为曾经有……
a female. It's a great story, but where do all the incidental details come from? It's a kind of just so story, isn't it? Yeah. I mean, I think it's clear that the story of Pope Joan reflects a very obsessional concern for the masculinity of the Pope, and he has to have his full tackle. I mean, this is the point of the ritual, even though he's never going to use it. And so that leaves two questions, as it were, hanging. Right. You know, why does it matter so much that a celibate man is seen to be masculine? And of course, the question that I'm sure lots of our female listeners in particular would have been asking themselves, what's so wrong with a woman being a Pope anyway? Brilliant. Well, what a cliffhanger, Tom. I don't know the answer to either of those questions. I'm looking forward
一位女性。这是一个伟大的故事，但所有附带的细节是从哪里来的？这是一种“就是这样”的故事，不是吗？是的。我的意思是，我认为很明显，琼教皇的故事反映了对教皇男性气质的一种非常强迫性的关注，他必须拥有完整的装备。我的意思是，这就是仪式的意义所在，即使他永远不会使用它。所以这留下了两个问题，悬而未决。没错。你知道，为什么一个独身男人被视为具有男性气质如此重要？当然，我相信我们许多女性听众特别会问自己的问题是，女性当教皇到底有什么错？太棒了。嗯，真是个悬念，汤姆。我不知道这两个问题的答案。我很期待……
to finding out. So we will be back after the break, and Tom will answer those two thrilling questions. Bye-bye. Reviews, a splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Now, Tom, you were taking us masterfully through the legend of Pope James.
去寻找答案。所以我们休息后回来，汤姆将回答这两个激动人心的问题。再见。评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余味》。现在，汤姆，你正在大师级地带领我们了解琼教皇的传说。
But I have a burning question that I am guessing many of the audience will also have. Why in the Middle Ages, and indeed today, do Catholics take it for granted, A, that a woman cannot become Pope, head of the Roman Church, and B, that a woman cannot even be a priest? It's a very simple answer, really. It's because, according to the Gospels, Christ summoned men to be his apostles and not women. And therefore, according to Catholic doctrine, when priests handle the sacraments, they are doing so in persona Christi, in the person of Christ himself. And a woman cannot personate Christ, but a man can. Is that the claim? Yes, because there is also the notion which the Pope actually, when he reaffirmed this doctrine
但我有一个迫切的问题，我猜许多听众也会有。为什么在中世纪，乃至今天，天主教徒都认为理所当然：A，女性不能成为教皇，即罗马教会的领袖；B，女性甚至不能成为神父？这其实是一个非常简单的答案。这是因为，根据福音书，基督召唤的是男人作为他的使徒，而不是女人。因此，根据天主教教义，当神父处理圣礼时，他们是以“基督的人格”（in persona Christi），即基督本人的人格在行事。而女性不能扮演基督，但男人可以。这是他们的主张吗？是的，因为还有一种观念，教皇实际上在今年早些时候重申这一教义时也引用了它，这种观念源于保罗，即男人被视为基督的形象，而女性被视为教会的形象，即基督的爱人。所以当然，在性别平等的时代，这看起来可能非常厌女。
earlier this year, he drew on it, which derives from Paul, that man is seen as being in the image of Christ and that women are seen as being the image of the church, the beloved of Christ. So of course, in an age of gender equality, this can seem very misogynist. Well, I was about to say, lots of people listening to this will say, does this not reflect a deep seated, specifically Catholic, this would be the philip pullman take tom uh specifically catholic but also wider christian fear of women of sexuality generally of the body but specifically of women i mean there is absolutely no question that there is a deep vein of misogyny in medieval culture and we touched on this in the episode that we did on catherine of Siena. But Christian misogyny is qualitatively different to the misogyny that is completely taken for granted in antiquity.
嗯，我正要说，很多听着这个节目的人会说，这难道不反映了一种根深蒂固的、特别是天主教的——这会是菲利普·普尔曼（Philip Pullman）的观点，汤姆——特别是天主教的，但也包括更广泛的基督教对女性、对性行为、对身体，但特别是对女性的恐惧吗？我的意思是，毫无疑问，中世纪文化中存在着深刻的厌女症，我们在关于锡耶纳的凯瑟琳的那一集中谈到了这一点。但基督教的厌女症与古代完全被视为理所当然的厌女症在性质上是不同的。
So Aristotle, who is the great authority for this throughout antiquity, he categorizes women as essentially being inadequate men, men who haven't quite made it to being men. At the same time as the legends of Pope Joan are starting to crystallize, at exactly the same time, Aristotle is coming to be enshrined at the heart of West European Latin scholarly traditions. There is a huge temptation for clerics who are all men, who are all as oozing, as bleeding, as being like bogs that will engulf the man who is foolish enough to stray into their depths, as it were. Increasingly, over this period, wherever Aristotle is being taught, and he is coming to be taught pretty much everywhere in Latin universities, the Daughters of Eve are coming to be measured
所以亚里士多德，他是整个古代这一领域的伟大权威，他将女性归类为本质上是不完美的男人，即那些还没完全进化成男人的男人。就在琼教皇的传说开始结晶的同时，就在同一时间，亚里士多德正被供奉在西欧拉丁学术传统的中心。对于那些全是男人的神职人员来说，有一种巨大的诱惑，他们把女性视为渗出的、流血的、像沼泽一样会吞噬那些愚蠢到误入其深处的男人的东西。在这一时期，无论亚里士多德在哪里被教授，而且他几乎在所有拉丁大学里都被教授，夏娃的女儿们正开始被……
by standards that are less biblical than Greek, than Aristotelian. But the problem is that you still have to square these views, these Aristotelian views, with the Bible. The Bible doesn't really allow for that kind of Aristotelian notion that women are just an inferior version of men. This is acknowledged by Thomas Aquinas, who is the greatest of the interpreters of Aristotle in this period, who admits that women can't simply be understood as defective versions of men, because in Genesis, it is explicitly stated that women as well as men are images of the divine. Aquinas acknowledges that the body of Eve was ordained by nature for the purposes of generation, and that this is the point of correspondence because God
用那些与其说是圣经的，不如说是希腊的、亚里士多德的标准来衡量。但问题是你仍然必须将这些观点，这些亚里士多德的观点与圣经相协调。圣经并不真正允许那种亚里士多德式的观念，即女性只是男人的劣等版本。这一点得到了托马斯·阿奎那（Thomas Aquinas）的承认，他是这一时期亚里士多德最伟大的诠释者，他承认女性不能简单地被理解为男人的缺陷版本，因为在《创世记》中明确指出，女性和男性一样都是神圣的形象。阿奎那承认，夏娃的身体是自然为了繁衍的目的而设定的，这就是对应点，因为上帝……
is the universal author of nature. Therefore, the body of Eve exists no less in the image of God than the body of Adam does. I think that it's really telling that this is the intellectual background to the age when the legend of Pope Joan is starting to clarify, because there is a real, real obsession in this period on the part, again, of male clerics with the idea of Christ himself as being female. So in the Bible, Christ does compare himself as a mother hen who collects her chicks under her wings. Even a scholar as great as Anselm, writing a couple of centuries before, he says, praising Christ, truly, Lord, you are a mother. Bernard of Clairvaux, the great preacher who inspires the second Crusade, compares himself to a nursing mother with breasts filled with the milk of doctrine. Dominic, you're looking very
是自然的普遍创造者。因此，夏娃的身体作为上帝的形象，并不亚于亚当的身体。我认为，这是琼教皇传说开始清晰的那个时代的知识背景，这一点非常能说明问题，因为在这一时期，男性神职人员再次对基督本人是女性的观念有着非常非常强烈的执念。所以在圣经中，基督确实将自己比作一只母鸡，将小鸡聚集在翅膀下。即使是像安瑟伦（Anselm）这样伟大的学者，在几个世纪前写作时，他在赞美基督时说：“主啊，你确实是一位母亲。”伯纳德·德·克莱沃（Bernard of Clairvaux），那位激励了第二次十字军东征的伟大传教士，将自己比作一位哺乳的母亲，乳房里充满了教义的乳汁。多米尼克，你看起来非常……
Protestant on the Zoom. That's not an analogy I would choose. As I say all this. And so, there's nothing shameful in male priests, male clerics, describing themselves in female terms and thinking of God the Father as simultaneously being a mother. And the church is a mother, of course, right? Mother church. Absolutely. But the question is, what does this mean for women themselves? Because on one level, clearly it does elevate them. This is the age where devotion to the Virgin is kind of universal. Again, we've mentioned Catherine of Siena. I mean, she is a hugely significant figure in the 14th century. She is seen as being holy in a way that is somehow more total and stranger than any man can hope to possess holiness. So that is a counterpoint to the parallel misogyny that you definitely get.
Zoom上的新教徒。这不是我会选择的类比。正如我所说的一切。因此，男性神职人员、男性教士用女性术语来描述自己，并认为圣父上帝同时也是一位母亲，这并没有什么可耻的。当然，教会本身就是一位母亲，对吧？圣母教会。绝对是。但问题是，这对女性本身意味着什么？因为在某种层面上，这显然提升了她们的地位。这是一个对圣母的崇拜几乎是普遍存在的时代。我们再次提到了锡耶纳的凯瑟琳。我的意思是，她是14世纪一个非常重要的人物。她被视为圣洁，这种圣洁在某种程度上比任何男人所能拥有的圣洁都更全面、更奇特。所以，这与你肯定会遇到的那种平行存在的厌女症形成了一种对立。
And this whole idea that the Pope is still alluding to today, in 2023, the idea that Christ is the groom, the church is the bride. This is what underpins the Gregorian reform. Because if the church is Christ's bride, then this explains why emperors and kings can't be allowed to get their grubby rapist's fingers on her. That's the whole essence of it. But it also, at the same time, explains why priests have to be celibate. Because if they're not celibate, then their fingers too are grubby. They lack the purity that is required to handle the sacraments of the bride of Christ. Right. So the priests are married to the church. Yeah. The church is a virgin bride. Simultaneously, their mother and their virgin bride. And if they take another bride,
而教皇在2023年的今天仍然在暗示的整个观点，即基督是新郎，教会是新娘。这正是格列高利改革的基础。因为如果教会是基督的新娘，那么这就解释了为什么不能允许皇帝和国王把他们肮脏的强奸犯之手伸向她。这就是其全部本质。但与此同时，这也解释了为什么神职人员必须独身。因为如果他们不独身，那么他们的手也是肮脏的。他们缺乏处理基督新娘圣礼所必需的纯洁。对。所以神职人员与教会结婚了。是的。教会是一位处女新娘。既是他们的母亲，也是他们的处女新娘。如果他们娶了另一个新娘，
they are cheating on the church. Absolutely. And so the implications of this for women is very paradoxical because simultaneously it's serving to equate them to the radiant purity of the church, but also casting them as temptresses because it's women who will seduce priests from their godly, celibate role. I've just noted down here one commentary on women by a priest, but there are multitude equivalents. The woman is the confusion of man, an insatiable beast, a continuous anxiety, an incessant warfare, a daily ruin, a house of tempest, a hindrance of devotion. When you look at it in those terms, you can understand why the idea of the most eminent of all priests in the Catholic church having to have his tackle, his manhood verified,
他们就是在背叛教会。绝对是。因此，这对女性的影响是非常矛盾的，因为它在提升她们与教会那种光辉纯洁性等同的同时，也把她们塑造成了诱惑者，因为正是女性会诱使神职人员背离他们神圣的独身角色。我刚才在这里记下了一位神职人员对女性的评论，但还有无数类似的评论。女人是男人的困惑，是贪得无厌的野兽，是持续的焦虑，是不断的战争，是每日的毁灭，是风暴的温床，是虔诚的阻碍。当你从这些角度来看待它时，你就能理解为什么天主教会中最杰出的神职人员必须验证他的生殖器、他的男子气概，
would have such a kind of resonance. So that's, I think, from the masculine perspective. I think that's how men are seeing it. But again, lots of listeners, and again, I'm sure lots of female listeners especially, may be wondering whether there is anything in this theology, this idea that God, Christ can be female. Is there anything in this that leads people in this period to argue that actually women can be priests, they can be cardinals, maybe they can even be a pope? And the answer amazingly is yes, that there is an extraordinary episode. It's like something out of The Name of the Rose, Umberto Eco novel. And it's set in the late 13th, early 14th century. So again, the
会有这样一种共鸣。所以，我认为这是从男性的角度来看的。我想这就是男人们看待它的方式。但同样，许多听众，尤其是许多女性听众，可能想知道这种神学中，即上帝、基督可以是女性的观点中，是否有什么东西。在这个时期，是否有人据此认为女性实际上可以成为神职人员，她们可以成为红衣主教，甚至可能成为教皇？令人惊讶的是，答案是肯定的，有一个非凡的插曲。这就像翁贝托·埃科小说《玫瑰的名字》里的情节。它设定在13世纪末、14世纪初。所以，再次回到
period when all the stories of St. Joan are starting to clarify. And it is focused around a remarkable woman called Guglielma. And the traditions that are told about Guglielma, because we have very unreliable sources for her life for reasons that will become evident, but to the extent that we know them, she is said to have been a noble woman in Bohemia, which like Mains is part of the empire. She is said to have married an English prince. So again, there's a kind of English link as in the stories of Pope Joan. And she's said to have come to Milan. So that is Italy. Yes. Just as Pope Joan is said to have come to Rome. And she comes to Milan and she lives a life of
圣琼的故事开始清晰起来的时期。它围绕着一位名叫古列尔玛的非凡女性展开。关于古列尔玛的传统说法，因为我们关于她生平的资料非常不可靠，原因稍后会变得显而易见，但就我们所知，据说她是一位波希米亚的贵族女性，波希米亚就像美因茨一样，是帝国的一部分。据说她嫁给了一位英国王子。所以，就像教皇琼的故事一样，这里有一种英国的联系。据说她来到了米兰。所以那是意大利。是的。就像教皇琼据说来到罗马一样。她来到米兰，过着
absolutely spotless poverty and charity. So there are kind of weird echoes in the biography of Guglielmo of the story that's told of Pope Joan. Now, Guglielmo dies in around 1280, and she is buried in an abbey at Chiaravalle, which is a district south of Milan. It's now a part of Milan itself, but back then it was a kind of separate place. And her grave becomes a great object of pilgrimage. People come, they pray before it, miracles are performed, candles are lit, and she's given a kind of popular canonization. She's come to be seen by the pilgrims as a saint. And there are many, many cults like this. It's nothing particularly unusual. But then in 1300, something absolutely astounding happens, which is that a whole team of inquisitors arrive in the
绝对纯洁的贫困和慈善生活。所以古列尔玛的传记中有一种奇怪的与教皇琼的故事的呼应。现在，古列尔玛在1280年左右去世，她被埋葬在基亚拉瓦莱的一座修道院里，那是米兰南部的一个区。它现在是米兰本身的一部分，但在当时它是一个相对独立的地方。她的坟墓成为了一个伟大的朝圣地。人们前来，在它面前祈祷，奇迹发生，蜡烛被点燃，她被赋予了一种大众化的封圣。她被朝圣者视为圣人。像这样的崇拜有很多很多。这并没有什么特别不寻常的。但到了1300年，发生了一件绝对令人震惊的事情，那就是一整队宗教裁判官抵达了
abbey and they have not come as pilgrims. They have not come to show their respect. Instead, they have come to desecrate Guglielmo's tomb. So they brought crowbars, they open it, they scoop out the body, they light a fire and they toss the corpse of Guglielmo onto the fire and they burn it utterly. And then they get the ashes and they scatter them to the winds. And then they go back into the abbey and they pulverize the tomb of Guglielmo and they trample down all the icons and images of her. And this is an amazing way to treat a woman who is being viewed by pilgrims as a saint. So you may wonder, what is going on? Well, what is going on?
修道院，他们不是作为朝圣者来的。他们不是来表示敬意的。相反，他们是来亵渎古列尔玛的坟墓的。所以他们带来了撬棍，打开了坟墓，挖出了尸体，点燃了火，把古列尔玛的尸体扔进火里，彻底烧毁了它。然后他们收集骨灰，把它们撒向风中。然后他们回到修道院，粉碎了古列尔玛的坟墓，践踏了所有关于她的圣像和图像。这对于一个被朝圣者视为圣人的女性来说，是一种令人震惊的对待方式。所以你可能会问，发生了什么事？好吧，发生了什么事？
There is a clue in the fact that even as Guglielmo's body is being destroyed, so the abbess, the woman in charge of the abbey, the woman who has been supervising this cult, is arrested. This is all the more amazing for the fact that this woman, she's called Merefreda, she is a cousin of the most powerful man in Milan, Matteo Visconti. The Visconti, through the 13th into the 14th century, are the rulers of Milan, but he can't save his cousin. She is condemned. She is burnt at the stake, accused of having preached an absolutely terrible heresy, a subversive, arrogant, grotesque body of doctrines. And what Mayor Freyda has been teaching the nuns in her abbey is that she, Mayor Freyda, is destined to become Pope.
有一个线索，那就是即使在古列尔玛的尸体被销毁时，修道院院长，即负责修道院的女性，一直监督这种崇拜的女性，也被逮捕了。这更令人震惊，因为这个女人，她叫梅弗雷达，她是米兰最有权势的人马泰奥·维斯孔蒂的表亲。维斯孔蒂家族在13世纪到14世纪统治着米兰，但他无法拯救他的表亲。她被判刑。她被处以火刑，被指控宣扬了一种绝对可怕的异端邪说，一种颠覆性的、傲慢的、怪诞的教义体系。而梅弗雷达一直在教导她修道院里的修女们，她，梅弗雷达，注定要成为教皇。
So how has Mayor Freyda come to this conclusion? Yeah, a feminist theologian from the 13th century. Incredible. We do not have detailed records of this because all the documents relating to Guglielmo and Mayor Freyda that the Inquisitors could find were burnt along with both Guglielmo's body and Mare Freyda herself. But there are fragments that report that Guglielmo, when she came to Milan, and I'm quoting here, claimed that she was the Holy Spirit made flesh for the redemption of women. She baptized women in the name of the Father and of the Son and of herself. So this is the idea that the Holy Spirit, just as God the Son had become flesh in the form of Jesus, so now God the Spirit has become meme. I mean, it's slightly more than a meme. It's a kind of a sense of excitement. It's a sense of potentiality that is sweeping the Latin world in the 13th century and originates with a guy called Joachim, who comes from the Abbey of Fiore
那么梅弗雷达是如何得出这个结论的呢？是的，一位来自13世纪的女权主义神学家。不可思议。我们没有这方面的详细记录，因为宗教裁判官能找到的所有关于古列尔玛和梅弗雷达的文件都和古列尔玛的尸体以及梅弗雷达本人一起被烧毁了。但有一些片段报道说，古列尔玛来到米兰时，我在这里引用，声称她是圣灵化身，为了救赎女性。她以圣父、圣子和她自己的名义为女性施洗。所以这就是圣灵的想法，就像上帝之子以耶稣的形式化身为肉身一样，现在上帝之灵也变成了女性。我的意思是，这不仅仅是一个模因。这是一种兴奋感。这是一种潜力感，在13世纪席卷了拉丁世界，起源于一个叫约阿希姆的人，他来自菲奥雷修道院
in Southern Italy in the late 12th century. Joachim of Fiore teaches that the ages of the world are to be divided into three. There was the age of the father, which ended with the birth of Jesus, which initiated the age of the son. Now, in the 12th century, the world, the church, the Christian people are approaching the age of the spirit, which is destined to start in 1260, which by coincidence is the very year that Guglielmo is supposed to start in 1260, which by coincidence is the very year that Guglielmo is supposed to have arrived in Milan. So this is the context for it. And so this is why Guglielmo comes to be seen by her followers as being, and again, I quote, the Holy Spirit and true God. So she comes and then Myfreda believes that Guglielmo has instituted this new age in which
在意大利南部，12世纪末。菲奥雷的约阿希姆教导说，世界的时代要分为三个。有圣父时代，结束于耶稣的诞生，开启了圣子时代。现在，在12世纪，世界、教会、基督教人民正在接近圣灵时代，注定在1260年开始，巧合的是，这正是古列尔玛被认为来到米兰的那一年。所以这就是背景。这就是为什么古列尔玛被她的追随者视为，我再次引用，圣灵和真神。所以她来了，然后梅弗雷达相信古列尔玛开启了这个新时代，在这个时代
she will become the head of the church. Is that right? Yeah. So Mayfreda and her followers claim to have seen Guglielmo risen from the dead, just as Jesus had risen from the dead. Right. And they believe that this heralds this new age of the spirit when corruption will be scoured away from the church.
她将成为教会的首脑。是这样吗？是的。所以梅弗雷达和她的追随者声称看到古列尔玛从死里复活，就像耶稣从死里复活一样。对。他们相信这预示着这个新的圣灵时代的到来，届时腐败将从教会中被清除。
The papacy at this point is widely seen as corrupt, as characterized by greed and by cruelty. So the reigning pope at this time, Boniface VIII, is widely viewed as a man unworthy of his post. And the cardinal at which elected him is seen as having failed the Christian people. And so this is why Mayfreder is able to preach that the time has come for a complete cleaning out of the Aegean stables, get rid of all the men. So it won't just be the Pope who will be a woman, all the cardinals will be women as well. And the age of the Spirit will be a feminine one. It's an extraordinary, extraordinary story.
当时的教皇制度被广泛视为腐败，以贪婪和残忍为特征。所以当时的在位教皇博尼法斯八世被广泛视为一个不配担任其职位的人。而选举他的红衣主教被视为辜负了基督教人民。所以这就是为什么梅弗雷达能够宣扬彻底清理奥革阿斯的牛圈的时候到了，把所有的男人都赶走。所以不仅教皇会是女性，所有的红衣主教也将是女性。而圣灵时代将是一个女性的时代。这是一个非凡的、非凡的故事。
It's clearly, I would guess, emerging from the same swirl of ambivalences and paradoxes and tensions in the Christian world at this time that is giving rise to the story of the female Pope, Pope Joan. But male hegemony, the patriarchy proves too strong. The patriarchy strikes back, Dominic. Yeah. Because my Freda ends up being burned at the stake. And the story of Pope Joan, so you're saying that it's in this milieu that the legend of Pope Joan is written down as a kind of cautionary tale. Is that right? As an antecedent of this, a story to scare priests and cardinals and men generally. It is a cautionary tale, but it is also kind of playing postman's knock with the idea that there is something feminine about the
很明显，我想这与当时基督教世界中出现的关于女教皇琼的故事的同样的矛盾、悖论和紧张局势的漩涡中产生。但男性霸权，父权制证明太强大了。父权制反击了，多米尼克。是的。因为梅弗雷达最终被处以火刑。而关于教皇琼的故事，所以你是说正是在这种环境中，教皇琼的传说被写下来作为一种警示故事。是这样吗？作为这个的前身，一个吓唬神职人员、红衣主教和一般男人的故事。它是一个警示故事，但它也像是在玩一种游戏，暗示着神职人员的角色中有什么女性化的东西，
priestly role, I think. Right. Well, the celibacy, you're not sexually active as most men would have been expected to be, right? So that in itself demasculinizes you. But also this idea that if the priest's role is in persona Christi, is kind of Christ-like, and Christ compared himself to a mother hen sheltering her chicks under her wing, then there is something female about the priestly role. I mean, it's an issue that clearly generates all kinds of anxieties, but I think that these stories work when they do kind of make play with anxieties. So I think it's not just a kind of a salutary tale. It's a tale that kind of opens up avenues that then immediately get closed down again. And I think that that's why the echoes in the authentic story of Guglielmo and Mayor Freyda are so intriguing. And Dominic also,
我想。对。好吧，独身，你没有像大多数男人那样有性生活，对吧？所以这本身就使你失去了男性气质。但也有一种观点认为，如果神职人员的角色是代表基督，是某种基督式的，而基督把自己比作一只母鸡，把小鸡护在翅膀下，那么神职人员的角色中确实有女性化的东西。我的意思是，这是一个显然会产生各种焦虑的问题，但我认为这些故事在它们确实利用焦虑时是有效的。所以我认为它不仅仅是一个有益的故事。它是一个打开了随后又立即被关闭的途径的故事。我认为这就是为什么古列尔玛和梅弗雷达的真实故事中的回响如此引人入胜的原因。而且多米尼克，
of course, it anticipates the role that someone like Catherine of Siena, who we did an episode earlier this year about, is also so key. Because it's not like in this period, the church is completely closing down the idea that women can have a sacral role, dare I say. Because of course, just as the church is married to Christ, so Catherine of Siena becomes married to Christ. And to go back to the quotation we began the episode with from Jean de Mailly, the chronicler. So he writes that in the early 13th century, doesn't he? He does, yeah.
当然，它预示了像锡耶纳的凯瑟琳这样的人的角色，我们今年早些时候做过一期关于她的节目，她也是如此关键。因为并不是说在这个时期，教会完全关闭了女性可以拥有神圣角色的想法，我敢说。因为当然，正如教会与基督结婚一样，锡耶纳的凯瑟琳也与基督结婚了。回到我们这期节目开头引用的编年史家让·德·梅利的引文。所以他在13世纪初写道，不是吗？是的，他写了。
Does he believe it? I don't know what the rest of his chronicle is like. So I don't know whether the rest of it is very melodramatic and sensational, or whether it's very sober and serious. But do you think he believes that it's true? Or do you think he's consciously fabricating a story that matches the anxieties of his age? Both. I mean, I think he does think it's true. He wouldn't put it in his chronicle otherwise, but he's not writing as a historian in the 21st century would write. What happens, I mean, it happens, but everything that happens has a deeper meaning, a meaning that opens up lessons and teachings. And I guess that that is how he would see it. And that is how the story
他相信吗？我不知道他编年史的其余部分是什么样的。所以我不知道其余部分是非常夸张和耸人听闻的，还是非常清醒和严肃的。但你认为他相信这是真的吗？还是你认为他是在有意识地编造一个符合他那个时代焦虑的故事？两者都有。我的意思是，我认为他确实认为这是真的。否则他不会把它写进他的编年史里，但他不是以21世纪历史学家的身份写作的。发生的事情，我的意思是，它发生了，但发生的每一件事都有更深层的意义，一种开启教训和启示的意义。我想这就是他看待它的方式。这就是这个故事
is understood by the Roman church right the way up to the Reformation. For obvious reasons, it comes to take on a kind of different significance and becomes an embarrassment. Final question for you, Tom. This is such a fascinating subject. I'm going to assume we're not going to see a female Pope in our lifetimes. In our children's lifetimes, do you think there'll be a female Pope? No. Okay. Right. do you think there'll be a female Pope? No. Okay. Do you think there'll even be female Catholic priests? I wouldn't have thought so because I think it's so fundamental to Catholic teaching and doctrine that I don't really see how it can be reversed.
被罗马教会一直理解到宗教改革时期。出于显而易见的原因，它开始具有一种不同的意义，并成为一种尴尬。最后一个问题给你，汤姆。这是一个如此迷人的主题。我假设我们有生之年不会看到一位女教皇。在我们孩子的一生中，你认为会有女教皇吗？不。好的。对。你认为会有女教皇吗？不。好的。你认为甚至会有女性天主教神职人员吗？我本来不会这么想，因为我认为这对天主教的教义和学说来说太基础了，我真的看不出它怎么能被推翻。
Okay. Right. Without doing immense damage to the inheritance of Catholic doctrine that is now 2,000 years old. But I'm not a Catholic theologian, so who am I to say? Nor am I a prophet. You don't have a dog in the fight though, Tom, do you? I don't have a dog in the fight, no. But that would be my sense. You made it sound as though you would really care and you would be very disappointed about the centuries of Catholic theology, but I get the sense that you probably wouldn't. You wouldn't take it to the streets.
好的。对。而不对现在已经有2000年历史的天主教教义传承造成巨大的损害。但我不是天主教神学家，所以我有什么资格说呢？我也不是先知。你在这场争斗中没有利益相关，汤姆，对吧？我没有利益相关，没有。但这就是我的感觉。你说的好像你真的很在乎，而且会对几个世纪的天主教神学感到非常失望，但我感觉你可能不会。你不会走上街头。
Well, I say that because Pope Francis, who is seen by many conservative Catholics as being alarmingly radical in his views, say, on homosexuality or social issues, he's very, very conservative on this issue. So if even the least conservative Pope in recent times is conservative on this matter, I can't really see it changing, certainly within our lifetimes. Okay. All right. So on that bombshell, Tom, that was absolutely fascinating. What a strange and intriguing story that was. It was a nice companion piece, as you said, to our podcast about Catherine of Siena that we did in the summer.
好吧，我这么说是因为教皇方济各，他被许多保守派天主教徒视为在同性恋或社会问题上的观点令人担忧地激进，他在这个问题上非常、非常保守。所以，如果连近年来最不保守的教皇在这个问题上都是保守的，我真的看不出它会改变，肯定在我们有生之年不会。好的。好的。所以在这个重磅炸弹上，汤姆，这绝对令人着迷。那是一个多么奇怪和引人入胜的故事。正如你所说，这是我们夏天做的关于锡耶纳的凯瑟琳的播客的一个很好的配套作品。
And I'm sure you've got lots of saints and popes to come on the rest of Sydney, haven't you? If you'll let me. Yeah. So tune in in 2028 for the next appearance of a medieval saint or if tom has his way probably february february yeah yeah and we will see you all next time thank you for listening thank you very much tom tour de force goodbye bye-bye i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we host the rest is entertainment I'm Marina Hyde.
而且我相信你在剩下的悉尼节目中还有很多圣人和教皇要讲，不是吗？如果你允许的话。是的。所以请在2028年收听中世纪圣人的下一次出现，或者如果汤姆有他的方式，可能是二月，二月，是的，是的，我们下次再见，感谢收听，非常感谢汤姆，杰作，再见，再见，我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》，我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开了娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及提前获得现场门票，请前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。